number four spice it up so again you can
do see the first three steps you're way
better than ninety-nine percent of the
entrepreneur's out there who are talking
about themselves next up though is I
want to create a memorable and lasting
impression on my target audience doesn't
have to be something that everybody will
understand be really excited about but
it should be something that you're you
know your target audience will really
care deeply about so you want to leave a
one-sentence lasting impression on them
so we want to spice it up so the couple
ways to do it something really specific
so the only company that's available by
phone 24 hours a day whatever some kind
of staff you can put on there if if
service and availability is a big issue
in your industry then if you're the
company who is available 24 hours a day
I'm going to put that in that's
something that's memorable to your
target audience if it's going into
industry where everybody does that and
that shouldn't be your spice it up
because it's not it's not interesting
everybody does it to something specific
the max something funny that doesn't
offend anybody but is a humorous way to
get your point across so again it's
something around service you don't give
you my mother's phone number and if we
don't deliver you can parlour could be a
funny way to be able to get people again
to remember your message that would be
something that if if service is a really
important factor for your customers and
everybody's coming in and saying we'll
provide the best service you're going to
give them your mom's phone number so
you're going to better provide good
service next guaranteed so some kind of
guarantee is great it reduces the risk
because people want to do it more often
with you so I on time or 110 per cent of
your money back not just a hundred
percent 110% and you'll find almost
nobody takes us up the people who do
returns even if you're giving them more
than what they pay for is tiny tiny tiny
but you'll see that the people who will
sign up because of it goes up
dramatically to something you could test
that it may not be a money back
guarantee but some kind of guarantee
again that would be interesting
for your target audience and in some
kind of example so number one rated
according to you know whatever magazine
newspaper that you've been featured in
there some awards that you've won some
example that you can show that backs up
whatever claim they can make the point
of this step for spice it up is to take
everything that we've already said and
add something a little more memorable to
it so again it's easy to think is this
for me and I easily pass it on everybody
else we face we're bombarded constantly
with messaging from you know people that
were meeting or advertisements and so
it's hard to remember everything things
get thrown out so you need to have
something that will leave a lasting
impression so your exercise fill in the
blank my spicy sentence to make my
message memorable is and again does have
to be interesting for everybody but
something interesting for your target
audience so then we put it all together
so this is our step 5 and hopefully you
guys will all do this as you go back you
know after after this workshop you know
I are we help the type of people step
one who are frustrated with whatever the
frustration is then you explain why what
relief you offer and then you finalize
with your spicy sentence so here's one
for me this is what I use when I'm
pitching brands we work a lot with big
brains we're trying to target
entrepreneurs so we help brands as hell
of small businesses like tell us in
American Express who are frustrated with
the online marketing build communities
of massive engagement guarantee at least
10,000 people to your site with each
post that we create that is short
specific Cooley explains who are
marketing to and for my audience that
works very well so yes it good sit down
with me for 10 minutes and I could
explain what I do but it's really hard
to get that message across quickly so
you want to come up with this and this
is on our on our page up promotes the
service it's right there at the top bold
easy to see people read that and they
quickly make a decision is this for me
or not and if it is then they're
interested to learn more and will read
down on the page and if they're not at
least we bless an impression that they
might be a blue asks on to more business
so this is my example hopefully you can
use it to match up with your business
and when you're riding in to tell people
what you do or if you're writing to me
to tell me what you do I want to see
this kind of format not to encourage you
you guys go through this step send me an
email with this of what you guys do and
i wanna i want to see it and i'll give
you some feedback on it too I think
that'd be pretty cool to also learn
about what you guys are doing and in a
way that I can put the understand and
know maybe I could use your services or
least maybe refer somebody gods so
that's a challenge for those of you who
want to take me up I'd love to see those
come in so quickly there and then
practice so for this you know does it
actually explain your business hopefully
it's yes is it memorable and is it
really memorable is this something that
you know if you go back and you look at
it next week does it still really
reflect what you're doing is it
something that people are going to
remember and if something stranger set
this to you would you be curious to
learn one and as you practice it it'll
get better right there may not be
exactly what you write out but it'll get
better each time you practice you know
your first pitch is never as good as you
know your most recent pitch but it'll
get better each time you look through it
key step is to start and use that kind
of formula to get you through it
now quickly i also want to talk about
creating your hundred word bio and for
this this is really important because we
want to again as i talk before talk
about our story talk about how we
started it and let people know who we
are i think as people are trying to
decide if they're going to buy our
product or service the look at the
company's website and the look and the
about and they'll try to learn about who
the people are behind this parking
service the more expensive it is the
more they're going to do their research
and you want to be able to tell your
story really quickly and you can have a
longer version of it but you want a
quick story be able to show people what
it is that you do and why you do it
something interesting that books people
in this will also be really important if
you're doing any kind of media because
they're also going to want to know you
know quick by about you that they can
include but then you mention the themes
that the creative you so couple steps of
this one what makes your business unique
so what is it about your company this
ties back to the steps we've already
talked about what is it that makes you
know your business you need something
you're super passionate about if you
want any kind of awards that you're
proud of that people would recognize if
there's other milestones that you're
proud of if it's a revenue figure or
customer figure something that you're
really really proud of not fluffy just
putting in there but things that really
kind of get you going and if you have
any big company goal so if you're not
you haven't achieved much yet you can
say here is my goal i'd like to publish
this then you can put that into your
your scenes as well so right now we're
just putting a whole bunch of statements
down and we're eventually in a shortened
down such as what makes you unique
people want to buy from people again so
you have to show some personality you
can leverage yourself and really make
that a difference maker because nobody
else in your industry will be able to
copy you right and your uniqueness so
what hobbies you have you have to put in
some hobbies in there I'll you know if
you want marital status how many years
if you have a family or not some of your
favorites sports scene food music books
movie travel whatever it is something
that you really like doing any
accomplishments are really proud of that
you've gone through or any personal
goals that you really proud of and again
from here I just start writing
things out you know point form sentences
and then we'll eventually work the
shorten it down but I want to make sure
that in your bio you're talking not just
about your company which is what most
people do they just like about their
professional success for the
professional history and really went to
school maybe but they don't talk about
any of the personal side and I think
they're really missing out an
opportunity because if you see anything
on there that you can relate to then you
have a much better chance to be able to
close that customer and create a
relationship with them even though you
don't know anything about them yet but
they feel like they know you and that's
a big advantage except that we combine
them so mix up the personal and business
points try to get them into one
paragraph you're not it's probably gonna
be over 100 words to start from there
you want to shorten it down so take out
the stuff that is not you're not as
proud of you want to keep the the meat
in there that you're most proud and
passionate about and I think will spark
a reaction and then idea here is to get
it to a hundred words what I like about
100 words is it's short it's easy to
read it quickly give somebody an
impression of of what they're looking
for right if somebody comes your website
and click on the about they don't want
to read pages and pages of what you've
done right most people won't quick
hundred words yes he gets the idea
across and if they want to have more
information if they want your full
resume and everything you've done and
that might be required for some jobs
going after that's fine you can give it
to them but most people want it quick
and easy and I think reading what your
experience if you're looking up a
company you want to just get a quick
idea of who's behind it and 100 words is
enough to do it try not to go too far
over so this about me now this is on my
about page so if you go to my home page
and you click on my face there'll be a
link to my about page and this is how I
open it up it says about Evan in 99
works this quickly explains who I am so
I'll read it up quickly for you guys you
haven't seen it ready Evan chemical
helps entrepreneurs at 19 he built then
sold a bad pic software company 22 he
was a venture capitalist helping race
between half a million and 15 million
dollars you now runs Emma Carly calm one
of the world's most popular website for
entrepreneurs his goals to help 1
billion entrepreneurs he has helped set
two World Records work 20 hours per week
uses a stand-up desk rides a Vespa
raises funds to keep
and help create a line of entrepreneur
trading cards graduated from New York
soprano and enjoy salsa dancing being a
DJ and the drama Blue Jays so I started
off very professional talk about my
background pull out some numbers and
some stats I thought might be
interesting for people should what I do
now and also you know my goal for what I
want to accomplish with the billion
entrepreneurs and then the second half
is all personal stuff hobbies things
that I do personality traits some things
that how I run my company about the you
know how many hours I work and stand up
dusted it's business related but more
what I want to do and so that that you
know somewhere in there there's
something that needs people home also is
there something in there that people
want to talk about and that's great I
want to get that discussion going I want
people to come to this read it I want to
learn more be more curious the more time
they spend learning about me and wanted
to find out more and asking questions
the more likely they're gonna want to
you know hire me for whatever services
or buy whatever product so as much as
well so you want to try to do something
similar I want to give you this example
I kept it at 99 worth set of a hundred
whatever I thought it was good to be
under the hundred number but have
something like that you know about about
your name in 100 words and I know my
words whatever it is something short
sweet easy to understand easy to you
know pick out something from there that
people can relate to or at least possum
curiosity and you're way ahead of most
people who just put the formal bio of
how long they've been you know in the
business and boring right most people
are going to be bored of that so you
want to make it easy to understand and
exciting for people back to that shirt
on the last page wake me when you get to
the point right that's going to be for
most people so you want to make it quick
and easy to understand so that leaves us
how many more minutes ten minutes maybe
a couple extra prowl give it to us to
ask questions
you